in this short video I'm gonna talk about
what I do personally to help myself
sleep each night I do a lot of
activities to a day in the office and do
workouts and I need to be able to sleep
very very good and quickly so I can
actually rejuvenate so I never go to bed
with body stress so stress is stuck
energy in the body so we're going to be
using acupressure with a device that I
created to convert stuck energy which is
stress in the body to available energy
or relaxation because stuck energy is
it's like a tension in your body that
won't let it you relax all right
so basically we're actually fixing your
brakes and taking the foot off the gas
pedal all right
so there's two places that we're going
to be working on one is we're gonna
stimulate the relaxation centers in the
body which happened to be back here just
underneath the skull if there's any
doctors watching this the name of that
area of the body is the the center their
origin of the vagus nerve which is the
parasympathetic and the heart of the
locus coeruleus and the rathaiah nuclei
but for though everyone else don't worry
about that all you need to know is
that's where the brake pads are or the
on/off switch for your sleep so it's
right back there and we're going to
trigger that using acupressure before
bed so we want to induce a relaxed state
all we're doing is we're applying the
brake pads so you can start to turn off
but there might be a problem with the
gas pedal the on switch the accelerator
so number two we're going to be doing
some acupressure to turn off the flight
or fight mechanism and there's a lot
more to this but I'm going to show you
two of them today in this video on
myself so you can see how it works and
you can apply it to yourself as well and
that happens to be in the abdomen area
because if you think about it when
you're stressed you'll notice that you
have a lot of tension to your chest and
abdomen it really tightens up through
there so we're going to be taking the
foot off the gas pedal and applying the
brakes to induce a really good Delta
wave sleep so you can sleep through the
night and wake up feeling rejuvenated
so let's show you how to do that okay so
we have this device this is a I designed
this a plastic device it's a tripod so
you can use it on different surfaces and
it has different widths wide medium for
different types of people now this is
based on my hand with when I do
acupressure I wanted to create something
if I was going somewhere that I could do
I could pressure myself so I created
this for myself of course you can use it
one as well so so the first Center we're
gonna put this on a tall back chair so
I'm just going to show I'm gonna hook it
right back here in the top part of my
head right here and I'm just gonna allow
my gravity of my head go back on those
two points right there and you can see
that it's it's actually triggering a
stress release right now and I'm
actually feeling really calm through my
whole body and if I fall asleep you know
I'll try to wake up and finish this
video but basically what's happening now
is I'm extracting stress from the the
first Center and I'm actually kind of
triggering the relaxation centers in the
back of my upper neck and you can use
this on a couch you can use this in your
bed on a pillow or a tall back chair but
you want to just set the top of your
neck right underneath your skull and let
gravity kind of come down and hold that
pressure for two maybe three four
minutes and you're just gonna you're
just going to mount you want to take a
nap and what I like to do is I'd like to
also do a little lower do the lower
parts of your neck because it's going to
pull a lot of stress to the entire neck
and then I will take that's the widest
one right I will take the medium one and
I'll put that in the very lower part of
my neck
like right here yeah right here now if
you can see that so we're basically
holding pressure and the lower part of
my neck because that takes all the
tension off the upper shoulders so I'm
gonna go to bed and not have any tension
in my shoulders so I will be
working on all different all the
different segments in my neck and just
finding the tight spots and letting
gravity kind of pull the stress out and
again I use this on my pillow or a tall
back chair basically I have one in my
office in my house so I'll do this in
the topic chair my office I'll walk to
my room go to bed
typically or I will go in my bed and use
this as well but I like to use it in a
chair or on the couch and right now just
from that little bit of I did it opens
up my neck my neck comes really loose
and I feel really calm so that's step
one know step two because we're going to
take the longer portion and press it
into some points in the abdomen about an
inch to the right of your belly button
and then we're gonna press directly
inward like this pressing in right like
that and I'm going to hold this pressure
not so it's very painful but just so
there's pressure for about maybe a
minute or so and it's releasing stress
it this takes the lot of the
flight-or-fight stress out of your body
so I'll hold this and then I'll go up an
inch okay so I'm actually an inch to the
right of the belly button going straight
up to the bottom of the ribcage and then
I'll work a little higher higher and up
till I get to the rib cage and I'll just
hold this okay then I go to the other
side and I'll press a one-inch to the
left of the belly button
press straight in and hold that and kind
of go up those points right there and I
will probably do this one and bad
because it's a little more comfortable
and I'll just take my hand and let
gravity pull it in there and take stress
out of the abdomen now what I did is I
created a little bit of a download below
of these points if you want to see a
visual and relationship to the belly
button in the ribcage but I do this each
night before I go to bed because it
keeps the stress off my body so this
particular mechanism down here works on
taking the foot off the gas pedal and
then this one up here works on
stimulating the brake pads so you really
create a relaxed state so you can really
go to
a lot faster I just want to show you
this great technique so if you wanted to
get one of these you can go ahead and
order one to my left
actually your right my left and get it
and then I actually give you more videos
on using it in through the entire body
it's a very simple device it would be
cool also to use this on the plane if
you're applying somewhere the problem is
they they made I think it's a weapon of
mass destruction so I guess it could be
but I doubt it
so you might want to just put in your
suitcase and do it when you get there to
handle the jet lag so that's just two
different uses of this device and
there's many other ones but I think that
should actually get you started so I
hope you enjoyed the video I will see
you in the next one